have a broken bones yeah have I still
come back for more
absolutely today I'm off to me a
real-deal mega wrestler that diab Lisa
Rosa well that was me thank you well but
u s-- mess up a lot of people with this
we only actually use the weapons that
much Mexican wrestling is more about the
characters and and the moves really oh
well okay well do you want to sort of
show me some of these moves on meager to
get first of all I think you need a
character yourself well I do I do have
actually I'm one step ahead yeah look at
that
yeah nice I think you're ready paper
embrace you again okay let's do this
so where did your passion for Mexican
wrestling come from well actually
started off watching WWE I had two older
brothers so I was watching that pretty
much from birth I came along here which
is London School of Lucha Libre and
completely fell in love with it so how
about your nickname c'est la diabla
serosa means pink devil
my mother was an angel my father was a
devil so with the red and white I came
up pink do you want to be sort of like
the next uncle Gary Osteen or wherever
as far as I'm concerned I just what I
keep hearing on amazing matches here and
take a little breath anja to the best
level it can be so um you've got new one
around I can smash up for ya I can find
a buddy if you want to give it a go
definitely okay paper ombre you ready
yeah I'm ready
believe it
some worker yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like a sauna in there some of those
blokes are lucky to be alive
all in all I've had an eye-opening
experience I've learned to breathe water
like a mermaid I've flown drums around
cold disused warehouses and I've rode on
a bike with nine other blokes I cannot
do what they do for a living perhaps not
but it's been great to see what's beyond
the paper bag it's really inspired me
see what else is out there
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
seems like a no-brainer to me anyway
shut up boys
[Music]